A line connects two points.
A line is longer than it is wide.
Lines can be short, and lines can be long.
Lines can be straight, and lines can be curved.
You can bend lines to make a shape.
You can join straight lines together to make a shape.
You can join curved lines together to make a shape.
There are many kinds of shapes.
Circles, squares, rectangles, and triangles are geometric shapes.
We can use geometric shapes to draw many things.
When a line goes all the way around, it makes a circle.
You can use a circle, three small circles and a curved line to make a face.
On another piece of paper, draw a circle.
Then make it a mouse with eyes, ears, and whiskers.
Use lines and more circles.
If we cut a circle in half, we get two half circles.
You can use four half circles to draw a caterpillar.
On another piece of paper, draw a half circle.
Then make it into a fish with eyes, a tail, and fins.
When a line turns a corner three times, it makes a triangle.
Triangles have three sides and three corners.